dark square she's forced to do magnus
might well be forced to take the draw
now i don't think there's any way
forward the white queen and bishop alone
will not deliver checkmate the black
king will hide on dark squares and
white's king as well in mortal peril
um yeah i think us tell me if he's
calculated this
really accurately the world champion on
the brink of defeat he can give another
check with his queen he can give another
check with his bishop but it's not
leading anywhere there's no checkmate
and if there's no checkmate you have to
take the draw okay the king steps back
and now
and okay checking diagonally this is
always tricky in
uh
positions with queens so black has
to avoid a trap black's king cannot go
back where it came from because then the
white bishop would join the action with
a checkmate and now splendid he didn't
blunder magnus castle i think he was
hoping for a pre-move he gave up his
queen and it didn't work out
takes the win
wow he's actually smiling magnus carlsen
but this is a match loss for magnus
crawl